all right let's get to uh some notable
discussions from the david pakman show
subreddit
um you can find the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit and now 31 000 of you
are subscribed for free to the subreddit
um a user named plenitude opulence
posted a video of radical republican
congressman matt gates
having a beverage thrown at him in
pensacola
florida now my position on this stuff
has always been the same
i'm against it i'm against it it is it i
i know that this guy is disgusting i
know that this guy is depraved i know
that this guy represents
so much of what is wrong with the united
states at this point of time at this
time
i'm not denying that he's horrible if he
has committed crimes he should be
charged and he's currently under
investigation
he should be voted out etc
uh but throwing drinks at people you
know it's just it's beneath us
and uh i am against it so i know that
the video went viral and people are
laughing and it's all a big party
um i i think that this is um i'm i'm not
against
using incendiary language when it's
appropriate
or engaging in hyperbole for effect or
whatever but throwing drinks at people
uh i am against it i am very much
against it and very much the same
um user william mcadoo or mccadu
posted to the subreddit this story of
this anti-mask
anti-vaccine police officer 33 year old
police officer
who has died of covet 19. you know when
i see this
there are some people who see this stuff
and they gloat and they say this guy
deserved it
and hahaha he denied that you need
vaccines he was a cova denier was
against masks
and now he's dead i take no pleasure in
that i really don't and as i've said
before it's something about me
constitutionally
even when rush limbaugh someone as
disgusting as rush limbaugh
who made so many people's lives a living
hell by furthering
uh homophobia and xenophobia and all of
this stuff
i take no pleasure in seeing that rush
limbaugh got lung cancer
i take no pleasure in the fact that
people who loved him and
there were people i guess who did um
were are now
or did suffer i take no pleasure in that
and i take no pleasure in the fact that
this 33 year old police officer despite
being a kova denier
uh died uh i don't know i just i just
can't do it and i know some people are
taking pleasure in it but that
is not for me for me it's more about
uh everybody could be at risk and
we should get vaccinated because you
might be one of those young people that
gets it and dies
why take the chance and the the covid19
vaccine is so effective that it makes
the chance of you dying from covid at
any age group
dramatically lower and so go and get
vaccinated that's the lesson the lesson
is not
ha ha somebody died it's go and get
yourself vaccinated
lastly on the subreddit user b scolo
posted if and it's a big if
it's proven that the coronavirus
did leak from the wuhan institute of
virology
for which there is no public evidence at
this time hypothetically
what would the international reaction
and response be
china is arguably a superpower on the
same
footing with the usa eu etc
what consequences would they actually
face also
in this hypothetical scenario does war
with china become a serious platform
idea for the 2024 republican
presidential nomination
edit because i say i guess i should say
it i do not believe the virus leak from
the lab i suspect
the overwhelmingly likely scenario is it
jumped from an animal in the wild
yeah uh so you know what's really funny
about this republicans
um love to say joe biden is going to get
us into all these different
wars and they like to say joe biden is
soft on china and the reality is
i don't think joe biden's going to get
us into any wars
and joe biden has been reasonable on
china in my estimation
if indeed there was the discovery and i
mean listen when we say if
china obviously lied about cases early
they seem to be lying about deaths
there's no question in my mind china did
uh
tell lies about what was going on with
the pandemic that's
separate from the lab leak hypothesis uh
okay
um i do think that
if the word war isn't used it's it's
going to be probably something else
but if the lab leak hypothesis were to
even be proven partially and i'm not
talking about a bioengineered virus but
just it was being studied
and there was an accident right for
which there was no evidence at this time
very important to say
i think you are going to see the closest
to just straight up the beating of war
drums from republicans
heading into 2024 and it will all be
promised on biden
biden didn't do enough on the one hand
they've been saying biden's going to get
us into all these wars because he's a
warmonger i've seen no evidence of that
on the other hand uh they are going to
be saying biden didn't do enough on
china
and i whether it's trump or whoever it
is that is the republican nominee in
2024
will be alluding to something that will
probably feel very much like a war yeah
i think there's a real probability of
that
join the discussion on the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t
one of our sponsors purevpn is giving
you 47
off a one-year plan which comes out to
less than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them they're the only vpn
with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
off a one-year plan which is less than
six bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman